the Striking blue color makes stenter  caruleus one of the most beautiful  species of the genus stenter however  they also have many abilities you would  not expect to find in a unicellular  organism stento corrulius is most famous  for its regenerative abilities if a  stenterulius cell is cut in half each  half will regenerate into a normal  looking cell at half the size of the  uncut cell after healing and  reconstructing the missing parts of the  cell these half-sized cells will grow to  the normal cell size given time and  resources and the whole regeneration  process takes only around 48 hours and  you don't have to take our word for this  sometimes when preparing slides we  accidentally cut these massive cells and  the pieces of Center corrulius are left  alive in the slide within a day they are  almost fully regenerated and after two  days we can't even tell which is the  fragment and which are the unharmed  cells